so we're told here that f of X is equal
to this infinite series and we need to
figure out what is the third derivative
of F evaluated at x equals zero and like
always pause this video and see if you
can work it out on your own before we do
it together alright so there's two ways
to approach this one is we could just
take the derivative of this expression
while it's in Sigma notation the other
way to do it is we could just expand out
f of X and take the derivative three
times and see if we get an answer that I
guess makes sense so let me do it the
second way first so let me just expand
it out f of X is equal to let's see when
n is equal to zero this is negative 1 to
the 0 which is just 1 times X times X to
the 0 plus 3 so it's going to be X to
the third over 2 times 0 so that's 0
plus 1 factorial so that's just going to
be over 1 then the next term when N is
equal to 1 well now it's going to be
negative 1 to the 1 so now we're going
to have a negative out front negative
and there's going to be 2 times 1 plus 3
so that's going to be X to the fifth X
to the fifth power over 2 times 1 plus 1
so it's going to be 2 plus 1 is 3
factorial so is going to be X to the
fifth over 6 and then when X is equal to
2 it's this is going to be positive
again it's going to be X to the seventh
power X to the seventh power over 5
factorial is that right yeah five
factorial and 5 factorial actually let
me just write that out as 5 factorial 5
factorial would be what would be 120
it'd be 5 times 4 times 6 would be 120
but we could just keep going minus plus
and it goes on and on and on forever
well now is just to take the derivative
so f prime of X is going to be equal to
or just applying the power rule here
it's going to be 3 x squared minus 5 6 X
to the 4th plus 7 over 5 factorial X to
the 6 I'm just applying the power rule
minus plus we just keep going on and on
and on forever
the second derivative F prime prime of X
is going to be equal to apply the power
rule again it's going to be 6x to the
first minus four times five over six
I'll just write that is twenty over six
x to the third plus six times seven so
it's 42 over five factorial X to the
fifth and we're just going to keep on
going minus plus keep going or alternate
between minus something then plus
something on and on and on forever and
then we get to the third derivative the
third derivative is equal to let's see
the derivative of 6x is six and then we
have minus 20 times 3 is 60 over six
which of course is 10 x squared plus
five times 42 is what 210 over five
factorial times X to the fourth power
minus plus over and over and over again
and then we just evaluate this at zero F
prime prime prime at zero well when X is
equal to zero all of these terms with
X's are going to go to zero and you're
just going to be left with this six here
so F prime prime and the third
derivative value 8 zero is just equal to
six now another way that we could have
tackled this is just kept it in this
Sigma notation so we could have said
that F prime of X is equal to the
infinite sum and actually let me let me
line them up so this is where we did F
prime of X expand it out but we could
have said F prime of X is equal to the
sum from N equals zero to infinity and
you take the derivative here you're
going to get and you're taking the
derivative with respect to X so for that
purpose you assume everything else is
well the N is just going to tell us
which term work is going to tell us how
we change from term to term so if take
the derivative with respect to X here
use the power rule bring the two n plus
three out front so it's going to be
negative one to the N times 2n plus
three times X to the decrement the
exponent two n plus 2 over 2n plus 1
factorial
and then if you wanted to take the
second derivative and this is the same
thing as this if you take the second
derivative F prime prime of X well now
we're taking the sum from 0 to infinity
of negative 1 to the N let me move over
to the right a little bit so we have
some space and now we take this exponent
out front so you're going to have 2n
plus 3 times 2n plus 2 all of that's
going to be over 2n plus 1 factorial and
this is going to be times X to the 2n
plus 1 all I'm doing every time it seems
really complicated I'm just taking the
exponent out front multiplying it out
front and then decrementing it so 2n
plus 2 minus 1 is 2 n plus 1 and then if
I want to take the third derivative the
third derivative is the sum N equals 0
to infinity negative 1 to the N we take
this bring it multiply it so we're going
to have 2n plus 3 times 2n plus 2 times
2n plus 1 all of that over 2n plus 1
factorial and then that is going to be
times X to the X to the 2n X to the 2n
power now let's now evaluate this thing
when X is equal to 0 so f prime prime
prime of 0 is going to be the sum from N
equals 0 to infinity of negative 1 to
the nth power now this is going to be
interesting we're gonna have all this
business 2n plus 3 times 2n plus 2 times
2n plus 1 all of that over 2n plus 1
factorial times 0 to the 2n power now
you might be tempted to say well hey if
0 to these different powers maybe
everything is going to be 0 but remember
we're starting at N equals 0 so for any
N
that's not equal to 0 this 0 to that
power is just going to be zero and that
term is going to disappear kind of like
what we saw when we expanded it out and
so the only term that matters here is
when n is equal to zero and so this is
just going to be equal to because for N
equals one two three four five all the
way to infinity this this thing is going
to dominate it's going to multiply it's
going to be zero and you're just going
to zero everything out and so this is
just going to reduce to the first term
when N equals zero and when N equals
zero it's going to be negative 1 to the
0 this is going to be which is just 1 so
I'll just let me just write that as 1
times this is 3 times 2 times 1 over 1
factorial and then times 0 to the 0
which is equal to 1 so this is equal to
1 and so this is equal to 6 so either
way I think the first way we did it was
a little bit more a little bit more
straightforward a little bit more
intuitive closer to what you might have
seen before but it's important to
realize that we did the same thing both
times we just kept it in the Sigma
notation on this time to the right and
this this technique is useful because
you'll see it a lot in math where you
might want to do things a little bit
more of a general way and so it might be
helpful to take the derivatives while
you stay in that Sigma notation